hey everyone I'm here it's you melodic
Hummer alongside Sebastian me I look
good to see you mr. had them screaming
ah okay thank you
we're gonna try something different now
we're gonna test whether or not we're
gonna do better as a couple then we
would have done individually in tactics
and I believe that we will do much
better much better
Wow that's optimistic I still have faith
in that saying that too many cooks
creates too much problems well if you
see if you saw my abysmal performance
then we don't do not really you know how
a cubicle yeah I'm gonna have to meet
genius how do you think about this move
I think that's a brilliant move rook the
eight that's brilliant
okay it turns out having two heads might
be beneficial yeah definitely
two brains think better than one brain
isn't that correct especially with a
brain like yours yeah but that's the
idea that on my own I still would have
found that answer so it's your time to
step up dude I I don't see what's going
on here we know this is a mattre bution
yeah desperately yeah this is a rough
one because our knife is in trouble if
we move the knight then we're gonna lose
the Queen
oh the puzzle is black to defend all
right okay well that makes it much
easier
something like Queen e7 yeah and then
after the exchanges we keep and that was
easy black to definitive Eva took it for
granted that it was black to win okay
now it is black to win though okay it's
not cheating age sex I guess yeah do you
have the follow-up or do you just think
it's gonna be it has to be correct right
yeah it kind of does doesn't it yeah
question is what did we do now
ah I know I know this one oh wow yeah
brilliant yeah that's good okay so far
so good between the eight it's too
tempting yeah but what if it's wrong
yeah that's a good point it's gonna be
embarrassing but yeah you're right it
has to be this one
yeah it's mate rook takes at least a
sweet amazing didn't take much time
would things be one yeah very good you
got there just before me I was about to
see you say the same thing I've seen
this one before yeah I like this one
it's reminiscent of something Fisher did
once extremely cute I feel like I'm
getting diabetes by looking at that
hustle that's sweet yes two different
things I think this one no yeah things
up tonight I don't see any defense yeah
this is a mm puzzled well I don't know I
feel like the ones I got last time was
they were more difficult you had a rough
time yeah I remember
no 1,600 puzzles today this is one first
and then get the rook involved Yeah
right that does seem correct
what about pg4 what do you do that I
have no idea I'd have sex first I was
consuming something would happen but if
Knight f6 then the King kind of run back
trying to calculate it you're right
g4 might be correct G before or we die
six and that night at six
no I don't believe pick it I have
because a king h4 then you have a not f5
right King h3 rook h1 but I could be
lost track of what you're saying I'm
just like g4 king takes Knight of 6 it's
still nowhere close I can't except for
ok I have no idea what you're thinking
about but maybe your check is good after
all
yeah that has to be the correct move
jack can you stick some that check check
check
yeah no I'm liking your suggestion check
and then check yeah no way yeah because
King g7 is like coming next right I'm
confused
how about if we get something to this
square there's game takes g6 right
struggling to see the follow up is check
as much as we've Canada ah no check in
the 98 oh yeah okay we both made
contributions well done to brains are
better than one I think that issue yeah
officially two brains work together
better than one we look forward to
bringing you more that content from the
tactics frenzy and feel free to check it
out it's in beta testing so we're still
in need of your feedback to make it even
better and we'll see you around next
time